good afternoon my Scotia as you know
parole and a privilege it's a mistake
but it happened and if I were to be
released I would um I would just want
the simple life I just want to hold down
a job make some friends you know pay my
bills even if this was possible it made
20 people other people why do you need
to do this cuz it's what I'm gonna come
I want to take you to make seven pieces
of jewelry in five or six hours how long
if I told you you didn't have to live
with your mother anymore it's me the one
who asked why do you need a less
which man named ball which real name
8-ball what if we could make all this go
away in pairs as well sorry okay I mean
with my family I told him humming a
garage to finally tell you how big a job
knows I'm out of a job
I'll be back before you know can I come
with you this is mommy's very special
work trip
[Music]
in three and a half weeks the Met will
be hosting its annual ball
we are going to Robins not the ball
itself the neck of Daphne Kluger valued
at over a hundred million dollars
[Music]
revenge it's a twofer do not run a job
in a job
[Music]
user Smith can't we just go to this do
we have to steal stop yes
[Music]
is it genetic or the whole family like
this
literally
you
you